it would seem that they are laying the
basic groundwork for removing Joe Biden
and they're going to bring someone else
in now there have been many hints each
little grain of grain of sand being
added to the heat we had a report from
axios over a month ago about how
Democrats were lining up alternates but
now we have Joe Biden himself saying if
it weren't for Donald Trump he wouldn't
even be running again which is an
interesting suggestion considering that
Donald Trump is facing prison and facing
other means by which they are going to
try to stop him from running I believe
this story right here this is Joe Biden
on a fundraising C fundraising campaign
Trail suggesting he doesn't even want to
run it's only because of trump which
opens the door down the line for a clean
e a clean exit now we don't know exactly
how it's going to happen but uh nobody
really thinks that Joe Biden is going to
run some people do to be fair but
realistically how's this going to play
out so we'll dive into that plus we've
got some really good great topics to
jump through uh we'll talk about what
happened with that house that exploded
it's not the biggest story in the world
it appears that this guy maybe was just
crazy and his house exploded so we'll
get into that plus we have a weird story
from military.com about dozens of
military men and women who or or
military men perhaps who want to
overthrow the government oh boy this
one's going to be fun and then of course
we have a segment on jenz may be the
most conservative generation ever which
we'll have to explain what that means
but I actually think it might be true so
we'll get into that before we get
started my friends head over to cast
brew.com to pick up the best cup of
coffee you've ever had I gotta be honest
man I've been going around and going to
these coffee shops I order coffee none
of it's good I mean it's all okay I went
to a really nice restaurant it was I
shouldn't say really nice but it was
like I don't know like 35 bucks a person
so maybe that's not super nice but uh
their coffee wasn't that good I'm not
trying to be a dick but you know if you
want good coffee you got to buy cast
Brew Coffee Appalachian kns is the
favorite followed by Rise with Roberto
Jr and of course when you support cas
brew.com you're actually supporting this
show because we sponsor ourselves and
Cas Brew's Mission we're going to be
opening up coffee shops all over the
country to create physical hangout
locations the first location is
currently underway and we are working on
the the uh Corporation by which we'll be
able to open up thousands across this
country over the next few years but also
don't forget to head over to
timcast.net be members and then they
hang out and watch the members only show
or they sign up just cuz they want to
support the work we do and they want to
fund documentaries and other projects
we're working on you'll also get access
to our Discord server where you can
submit questions and call into our
uncensored show and even talk to us and
our guests so I strongly recommend that
it's a whole lot of fun don't forget to
also smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and everything else is Terry
Schilling hey guys thanks so much for
having me uh president of American
principles project which easy way to
describe it is the NRA style
Organization for families so we go in
and run campaign ads against Democrats
that are destroying the inance of our
kids and taking away pral rights right
on which is uh we we'll get into that as
well with um title N9 hearing happened
today we've got an epic exchange between
Riley gains and a Democrat and uh oh
that one pretty brutal Phil's back hello
everybody I am back from La my name is
Phil lanti uh lead singer of The Heavy
Metal B All That Remains anti-communist
and counterrevolutionary we're here with
Ian what's up dudes hello hi good to see
you back Phil oh look at that wow the
energy knocked the uh the UFO off its
off its Throne what's up everybody in
the audience I want special thanks to
you if you're listening you are
listening especially if you've been here
before because your attention is the
greatest form of currency in this
economy and it really does mean a lot it
means a lot that you keep coming back
and keep enjoying the show now some
might argue that money is the is the
most important currency to keep this
thing flowing but I think your
attention's up there arguably more
important let's just keep it
moving uh yeah good to have you back
Phil how much is gas costing nowadays uh
I don't know I rented a Tesla when I was
in LA
so it's part of the reason why I've been
talking about Tesla so much past few La
I've rented Tesla and I'm so I'm so
jealous of Tim's I'm just what are the
oh the the model S well I rented a model
3 and so I I fell in love with them I
want to get one real bad so the they
great okay I've been once but there's a
story right now people are watching Home
Alone and there's that scene where Kevin
mallister goes to the grocery store and
he buys a ton of stuff and she's like $9
whatever no $19 it's $19 yeah and then
in like two and then in like 2010 it was
40 and now it's 80 yeah but uh yeah
let's let's let's jump into this first
story we got this one from the Boston
Herold ladies and gentlemen Biden says
he wouldn't be seeking reelection if
Trump wasn't running which is the
weirdest headline because if it's anyone
other than Joe Biden Trump loses
according to numerous polls so let me
break this down Biden claims he's at
here's a quote if Trump wasn't running
I'm not sure I'd be running but we can't
let him win Biden said at a fundraiser
at a private event near near Boston
according to a pool report Biden just
celebrated his 81st birthday he went on
to warn that Trump has made clear what
his plans would be if he wins Trump's
not even hiding the ball anymore he's
telling us what he's going to do he's
making no bones about it Biden cited
Trump's comments he's out for
Retribution if he wins Biden is just
really trying to get me to vote for for
Donald Trump here but let's slow this
down Biden's claiming that he wouldn't
be seeking re-election if Trump wasn't
running that's the headline that's the
story if Biden didn't run there's a poll
from NBC showing that any other
Democratic candidate is 46 to Trump's
40% but with Biden it's like Trump 43 to
like Biden 39 which is to say Joe Biden
just admitted he's a trump supporter and
he wants Trump trump to win and that's
his true intention I I'm loving this
this is hilarious so Biden wants
retribution too yeah and he's like you
know come on man you know if Trump's
going to win I got to be here if I leave
he'll lose I guess I love it I I just
think it's so lame right like you want a
president that has a vision for what he
wants to accomplish in the in the
country right and and he's saying he's
just running to stop Trump like you you
need an altruistic president with a
vision I mean we obviously know he
doesn't have that that's not a surprise
to us but it's lame that he's actually
admitting it I fully agree we want
somebody with a vision that's like one
of my number one on my bucket list of to
do for a president is give me something
to live for what's the next 20 years
going to look like bro I want I want a
president that has a vision about like
not doing stuff all these presidents
that like do things like I I want a
president that wants to do less I we
have the the largest government in human
history well to to clarify my argument
if he's like I'm going to shut down this
organization and this organ plan okay
okay I'd be open to that but I I want
some longterm like how you are my kids
going to be in 20 years and why you you
want the most powerful job on Earth you
better give me a reason I think one of
the things that's actually helping
Democrats is they don't need to campaign
on kids because liberals don't have kids
so it's it's really simple they they
they they target the you those she those
viral videos about dinks I was just
going to say do you think this like the
dink stuff is
is no kids what does dink double income
no kids and so uh Biden is basically I'm
going to forgive your student loan debt
why so you can go party baby I just got
an email was I telling you guys about
that I was telling Luke about it while I
was down there on we are chain show best
political show.com that I got an email
like last week hey by the way we you
have no more debt I just saw all of my
student debt I thought it was like 8,000
of the 19,000 was gone it was all of it
it's all gone and then it went 180,000
more people got that same email so wait
how much how much did they forgive uh
for me total 19 thou I paid off 6800 is
that income I don't know IRS might
that's why people like hey that might be
considered income I'm like well I didn't
get it it just disappeared I didn't so I
got I'll find out next year if that's an
income if they forced repayment early
look when when when Oprah Winfrey gave
everybody those cars they're like no
that's income and and and there was a uh
now that's a little different you're
giving a car you're giving value but
there was also uh occupy did this thing
where they were paying off medical debt
so what you what they would do is they
would contact the uh uh the hospitals
and say this person's been delinquent
how long okay we'll pay off their debt
for 10% and so someone would owe 10
grand and they would pay $1,000 and wipe
their debt or even or even less pennies
but people were then pointing out hey
they have to report that as income
because you paid their debt off what's
so dirty about this is if they took I
had like say $10,000 left to pay off
that's my and if they force me to pay
that back early and then they're going
to tax me on that forced repayment
that's like pure I mean that's my debt
you can't pay my debt back without my
consent that's insane especially if you
tax my friends to pay for it right that
would be the most epic move by democrats
is to like forgive every all the debt
but then tax everyone on the forgive
debt so now they all have to pay more
money and they have debt to the
government Accel yeah un unsolicited
accelerated repayments like the but so
it's like someone's got a loan with a
private you know or they're all Federal
loans I guess that are being forgiven so
yeah even if it's if it's not taxed it's
still insane that if they've taxed my
friends to pay for it that's like
Insidious there's there is no there's
nothing that we've discussed that is
beyond what the government has already
done in like historically done the
government like Japanese internment
camps are infinitely worse than them
taking people's money for taxes or or I
mean whether that's the the extreme that
the the US government has done is stuff
like Jim Crow or or or internment camps
um when it comes to actually like you
know monetary policy and your property
and stuff the government demanded that
everyone turn in any gold they had any
any gold they owned at
all longer allowed to own it so that
kind of stuff government does those kind
of CH makes those kind of decrees and
and and stuff all the time and it's
we're going to we're going to see uh
this student loan repayment is instant
inflation yeah instant because money
that wouldn't would not have been in
circulation is now instantly in
circulation and the argument is it'll
stimulate the economy sure and now it's
going to immediately result in in Rapid
inflation as more people are spending
more money very very rapidly it's uh
it's it's it's such a dirty move and I
you know one of the dirtiest things
about it I do think we're facing a
self-correcting problem you know you got
these viral videos where it's like a man
and a woman and they'll film each other
I'm a dink I can go and do this because
I don't have kids and you I'm a dink I
can do this and it's these people are
excising themselves in the gene pool
they're not this these ideas will cease
to exist Democrats are utilizing that
short-term opportunity to win political
power and then try and maintain a system
which slowly just shuffles people off
into to an an ideology that results in
them excising them from the Jee pool I
wish it' excis the ideas but since
they're making internet video the stupid
ideas stay around for people like long
after those two dinks are gone that
someone's going to see that video and be
like they must have had a great life I
should be a dink too I just agree you
don't think I I believe you're half
correct the video will process people
can see it it may influence some people
but the reality is people who are like
imagine if a video popped up and there
was a a guy being like I took a dump on
my floor that means I don't got to hire
a plumber you watch that you'd be like
that's the stupidest thing I ever heard
I would never do that that's right
that's what might happen with these
videos if if liberals aren't having kids
and they're aborting their kids and the
the rate at which they reproduce is
dramatically Lower Blue states allow
abortions and red states don't let's
just make it very very simple for
everybody the the the one reason
conservatives should be celebrating the
the overturning of roie Wade is not that
it's made abortion illegal in some
places it's that it's given them a
guaranteed path to long path towards a
long-term victory because blue State's
populations will decline they already
are there's already an exodus and
they're already not having kids and now
they have an opportunity to abort up to
the point of birth y if you were to ask
me I would say that Democrat politicians
hate Democrat voters more than anyone
else I got kind of this mixed feeling I
was thinking earlier about this about
people that are changing their gender or
getting surgeries on their genitals so
that they can't have kids anymore or
they're just opting out like in a way
it's like you might think okay that's
that's fine and good because that means
they'll weed away and it's like maybe if
those people are mentally ill or if
they're just have some sort of illness
then we need less mental illness in the
system that's maybe that's okay but the
reality is I want less I I agree like
less ill people is good but that doesn't
mean I don't want them to be sick in the
first place I want to find out what's
making these people this way and solve
that and fix it it's it's that they
don't have any family it's that they
don't have any kids right like I look I
know that's not making them sick no no
no but it's making them immature it's
yeah that's making them liberal so like
here's how I view it look I know I'm a
freak I got six kids with our seventh on
the way we like our kids we like our
family it's it there's something
mysterious about it though in that it
forces you to grow up it forces you to
sacrifice like when you've got screaming
kids the next morning you're a lot less
likely to get trashed the night before
you got you got to make a video with
your wife where you're like I'm a parent
my kid mows awn for me I'm a parent I
don't got to do the dishes anymore we
put them to work now right like Saturday
morning so here's our system right it's
called Saturdays Saturdays we get up at
7 whatever time what you know they get
up 6:30 7:00 sometimes but they got to
clean the house clean the living room
clean the dining room you know put
everything away and they do that they
get donuts get to go to the movies get
to go to dve Buster something fun that
day it's D day it's the day that they
get to spend with their dad it works out
really well because we get a clean home
the lawn gets done like you're you're
you're not crazy Tim that's how it works
with big families that's how that's why
the families used to be bigger was cuz
you'd want to have more workers for your
for your farm or whatever business it
was and because they were like kids died
a lot at very very young ages babies and
and miscar and stuff so they're
constantly having kids and then they're
having a lot of them and then a kid
might die at four years old so it's just
like if you don't have kids you got to
keep doing it y but look man Democrats
continually uh offer up policies that
destroy Democrat positions look at their
policing policies they want to abolish
police in like the worst criminal areas
ever like they're they're I I'm I'm just
going to bring it back to without
getting into an abortion debate just the
idea that someone would look at you and
be like I think you should abort your
kid I like I I want to make sure like if
someone come to you and said you know I
want to make sure that if at any point
even the point of birth your wife wants
to terminate the pregnancy I'm going to
make sure she can you're going to be
like what are you saying but but but but
go back to the Dink videos right like
the Dink videos like if if my wife was
telling me that she didn't want to have
any more kids anymore with us or with me
I would be really insulted like you
don't love me enough to keep having kids
I look Grant we're we're reaching the
the the older age and and the maximum
limit of kids we're going to be able to
have but like if we first got married
and my wife was unwilling to have kids
with me it would hurt really bad and and
I think the same thing on her end I
think it would be insulting so it's it's
it's more than abortion but I think
that's a really good point like it is so
offensive to tell someone that they
should abort their children or that
they're they should be like it's it's I
don't think Democrats are coming out
being like abort your kids but they're
like you know I I want to make sure that
there is no restriction on your wife's
choice to abort your children it's like
you're basically saying I hope you die
like you should not so that's what
they're going for and it's just like the
end result of this in the longest in the
long run is red states are restricting
abortion blue states are allowing it
that's a pressure system that flows in
One Direction people are going to leave
Blue States and and you know I hear
people say yeah but Tim immigration I'm
like oh yeah yeah it doesn't matter the
illegal immigrants that are coming in
will still have the same access to
abortion which Planned Parenthood are
mostly in uh non-white areas so like I'm
sorry man like the Democrats seem to
really hate their voter base but but but
it it they create more voters the more
chaos and destruction that they Cause
right the more that we stray from
normaly and goodness and Beauty the more
everyone just thinks life sucks the
world sucks uh I'm a miserable person
Mis people vote for Communists that like
no happy person votes for communism it's
just not how it works and so they want
to cause disorder they want to cause
unhappiness they don't want you having
kids because that gives you an
investment in the future it gives you
something to look forward to um it's
they benefit from the chaos and and the
dysfunction I just figured out the uh
student loan repayment thing so you got
people who aren't paying back their
student loans right that money is
basically a debt that's a dead debt bill
you know you go to you go to some guy
and you're like where's my money he's
like I don't got it you can't beat money
out of him it's not there so what do you
do well you can garnish wages but then
people are going to lose their minds I
got a plan now if someone owes you money
and you're not going to get the full
amount what do you do you negotiate a
lower amount okay what can you pay me so
for hospitals and credit cards they'll
say what this this is a trick a lot of
people need to understand if you owe
like a th000 bucks on your credit card
and you're not paying it and they're
mailing you and mailing you mailing you
you can call them up and offer him 300
bucks and say you you cancel the whole
that I'll give you 300 bucks otherwise
you get nothing they'll say yes not
always but they'll say okay fine send us
300 bucks we'll close it out list is
what Joe Biden's doing he's looking at
all these student student loans and he's
like you know we're not getting any of
this money back let's forgive it all you
know why the Forgiveness qualifies as
income and then they don't get a tax
refund at the end of the year we get to
keep all their money so we're not
getting back the full student loan debt
but if someone owns o owes us 10 grand
and we pay them 10 grand that's 3K in
taxes they owe us then when it comes to
refund season they don't get a refund we
keep the three grand so we're not
they're not giving money with student
loan repayment they're just saying you
don't owe us anything anymore but that
counts his income now you got to give me
three grand yeah and and and instantly
comes out of your taxes without you
realizing it I'm wondering if we're
going to hear a lot of people come you
know like April you know just being like
whoa whoa whoa I didn't get a refund
this year yeah they took it because but
you know what's going to happen is they
going to be like well my student loans
paid off so yare but that that allows
the government to retain a large amount
of money there 84,000 people got paid
back 39 how much was this 39 billion 39
billion what what what's the average per
person and then slice off 35 or whatever
30% towards taxes MH and uh that's how
much they're going to keep from the
taxpayer without giving back their
refunds what is it like like 4,000
granted not every everyone's refund is
that high it's only up to like the the
uh um what is it what's what's the
threshold for where you don't pay taxes
like 15K or something uh I don't
something like that anyway here's a
story from axios just to to you know to
wrap up this portion of it it's not just
that Joe Biden said he was going to uh
he he wouldn't run if Trump wasn't
running even axio reported a month ago
Democrats have been working behind the
scenes a shadow campaign to get rid of
Joe Biden so we're about to enter the
New Year I hope youall are excited for
the holidays I know I am
and uh I I I just I don't understand how
they pull it off how do they swap out
Joe Biden is is this hint that Donald
Trump gets arrested or he's already been
arrested he gets he gets convicted
sentenced to prison and then Joe Biden
says look you know I said last year if
it weren't for Trump I wouldn't be
running now that he's convicted I know
he's running but this this he's he's
he's not here any he's not a threat
you's know I'm going to I'm going to bow
out and hand it off to somebody else
then the DNC declares Nome the or or
Gretchen Whitmer or something I just
threw up a little in my mouth when you
said that Whit she can't win so they
would never do Whitmer but some people
are they could do someone though like an
Annie Basher type you know out of
Kentucky yeah what do you think about
Nome I I'm not worried about Nome first
of all he looks like uh he looks like
the dude from American Psycho right like
he looks like the joker now is this I
want to push back I just want to make
sure I'm clear do you think that your
perspective
is is the is the Normie perspective or
do you think your P because the reason I
asked is I I was in California last week
and like my friends that are in LA and
stuff they generally don't look at Nome
and see the reptile that I see okay like
the
normies I think that someone like Nome
is
extremely
extremely appealing to normies and do
you think that your perspective is a
normie perspective or the perspective
that someone like us would have which is
that dude is definitely a reptile I
think your biggest mistake is that
you're assuming people from California
are normies like they're the weirdest
people there are
some agree with ph new Nome is a master
debater and that's why it was a big
mistake that Ron Des santz tried to go
up against him because there's no upside
Nome isn't candidate so the only thing
could happen is negatives for for Ronda
santis and the important thing to
understand about Nome is that as a as a
lizard person he can literally say
whatever he wants to convince people so
if he were to campaign or debate he'll
just say literally nonsense he'll he'll
he'll say in the great state of
California our GDP is up
7.3% homelessness is down 8.9% don't
believe the lies and he just makes it up
and then what are you going to do about
it who's going to call him out not the
media of course not there will be no
fact TR he can literally say whatever he
wants he can say that he he's with the
he was the the 15th guy to land on the
moon and that you know now he's here to
bring his expertise in oil to California
so so go ahead with your point but but I
I really want to know if it's if you
think it's if it's if it's something
that you think is is a nonbiased
actual guess of what the normal person
is or something that you personally
prefer no so no what I believe is that
the average normal human being has no
clue who Gavin Nome is for the most part
they have not been exposed to him he can
be branded and and and I think I'm not
I'm not desper you know I'm not
depressed about Trump going after him
Trump has a way of branding people and I
think that we have to fight differently
though we can't count on the mainstream
media to hold them accountable this has
to be fought at the local coffee shops
at the breakfast bars that that's our
plan with Cas Brew we got to have these
local coffee shops where when you walk
in we got TVs playing it's going to be
timcast IRL it's going to be Crowder
it's going to be daily wire that's the
plan let me jump to the story from CNN
ladies and gentlemen we got him house
oversight GOP released document showing
payments made by Hunter Biden to his dad
documents say they were for a car uh I I
wonder why CNN added that last bit
documents say they were for a car as if
that changes the fact that Hunter
Biden's business was sending Joe Biden
money you know it's like but it was for
a car I'm like oh so is that what the
corruption was paying for I don't know
what your point is but uh it wasn't that
much money it was
$1,380 for over 4 months so I think it
it it didn't was it four months but yes
he was directly paying him and so here
here's what I here's what I worry about
sure it's big you know Joe Biden
repeatedly lied about having no
involvement oh come on dude you're
getting reimbursement from his company
not only did he lie about whether he
talked to any of his business associates
he said he had nothing to do with his
business and now it's you did talk to
his people and you actually received
direct payments from his business for
which you were directly involved and
there's emails showing you being
directly involved y'all you're lying
here's the problem the House GOP seems
to be dripping this one out so slowly
none of these things are landing like
this story you know I see it lot people
are like oh hey look at this but it's
like oh okay I don't know one payment yo
if they came out with one big hit and
said here is all the proof and slam it
on the table and then maybe H back a
little bit they would they would it
would land much much better maybe the
plan for going to 2024 maybe the October
surprise will be the big Syndicate org
chart of Joe Biden on top with the red
yarn going from person to person but
when they do these stories it's like
yeah okay we we got him you know he's
sending money directly to his dad from
his company not personally it's still
such a thin sliver of a story I don't
think it hits that hard I don't think it
hits I don't think it hits at all right
I I'm not I'm not even convinced like if
you had some kind of significant
evidence
of significant
payments even that at this point I feel
like would be kind of brushed under the
rug by by the the corporate media at
least it would have to be something that
was absolutely devastating to not be
just ignored I really think that the the
the the you know corporate media is just
they're not going to report on it not
going to treat anything like it's a
serious I I kind ofation law I kind of
think this is all just a mistake for the
Republicans to be honest
no nobody ever cared about Joe Biden
nobody in 2020 cared about Joe Biden
nobody in 2019 cared about Joe Biden Joe
Biden could literally walk onto stage
and just take a dump right on the floor
and walk out and it would change nothing
his approval rating is in the gutter
because he's a bad leader in this
country is facing serious hardship but
no one's paying attention to Joe Biden
the man nobody thinks he's capable or
competent nobody wants to vote for him
they want to vote against someone else
so when when the Republicans come out
and they're like oh look what the bidens
were doing regular people are like yeah
we don't like him either but we like we
we'll vote for him so he it's it's it's
funny because Trump had that famous line
you know he could shoot somebody on
Fifth Avenue yeah well Joe Biden could
take a dump on on the middle of the Oval
Office floor with live cameras rolling
and it would change nothing there's so
there's been so many dumps on the floor
tonight I mean yeah yeah we're with the
with the all that talk with Gavin Nome
you know a lot of poop lot a lot lot
taking a dump on the floor you know just
in front of a bunch of people and but my
point is this when you combine my my
point by combining all of it is Yo
default liberal types literally don't
care what you do they don't they really
don't again like I'll reference like you
know one of my buddies in in California
we were talking and he's like you know
one of the things that I'm really sick
of hearing is like you know someone will
be like oh well this guy did this but
that guy did this and da d d and he's
like I don't care put then then
prosecute them all and I think that
that's the way that a lot of people feel
but they don't feel strongly enough
about Prosecuting people that are
ostensibly on their their team or their
side to actually want to to actually get
their representatives to do anything we
are so pasted there being a system of
laws in this country just it's not even
a point to bring it up right we know we
know Joe Biden did it we know what he
did we know about the payments we know
about the phone calls we know about the
flying to Ukraine we know why he did it
Victor shokes sworn testimony you can
lay it all on the floor we know the
crimes are being we know that on January
6 on one side of the building police
allowed people in pulled the barricades
aside fanned them in opened the doors
waved them in took selfies with them and
uh gave them tours and we know that BLM
in Atlanta set fire to a Wendy's and
were given a slap on the wrist and no
jail time they were given probation and
community service we know that the
federal government has not charged the
far- leftists who stormed the government
facilities outside of Atlanta at stop
cop City and it's a state level charge
only there there the the idea that there
is Law and Order in this country so when
I say you know Civil War people need to
start waking up to what's going on okay
the January Sixers the people who are
riding and violent I get it give them
criminal charges but they just arrested
a guy recently uh he he had flown to
Nashville for lady Ballers flew back
they arrested him on the spot even
though he had already answered questions
two years ago and he his story is that I
think he stood at the foyer of one of
the doors they opened and filmed and
then left didn't matter they came after
him anyway and they're going to get
every single person didn't he work at
the daily call or something like that I
think this guy was a republican
Republican uh uh Party official or
something okay yeah the point
is if you are on the right the feds are
coming for you there is no semblance of
justice and they don't care if you think
there is or isn't it's meaningless they
are wielding power and vience against
people raiding their homes if if you
know I guess you can tell me what you
think think Civil War is because I
suppose if if nothing's being done to
combat the corruption the Republicans
are super concerned about Joe Biden
getting payments and not uh so much with
January 6 you know now we're hearing
that um they're going to release the
remainder of the j6 footage but they're
going to blur faces and of course
everyone's saying yeah to protect feds
yeah of course because the feds already
have all the all the videos yep so here
we go there there's there's no there's
no functioning system of laws we were
swatted 15 times last year nothing was
done they never found out Marg T we know
we know we we we have a general idea of
who it was and how it happened and
everything lined up perfectly and no
matter how many agencies we call and no
matter how much evidence we submit they
just laugh and say no so margorie Taylor
green just did an interview with Tucker
goty released today or yesterday maybe
she's had the same thing they can't find
out who uh who swatted her they won't
give her any information well to be fair
her circumstance and ours are very very
different but can't they find out who it
is she I mean she brought up that the
unmasked Carter page right it is fair it
is fair to say that properly done it is
it is damn near impossible to Trek
there's there's there's there's
automated systems through routers
through through Russia through CH not
only that I mean you could take a yagi
Wi-Fi antenna from an apartment building
point it at a at a Wendy's a mile away
connect to a public Wi-Fi and then call
from Skype yeah and they're going to be
like they're going to say it was traced
to a Wendy's but how do we figure out
who who it was and all the footage it's
not that easy in our circumstance we
actually have uh uh
we actually have serious evidence
meaning that some of the addresses that
got swatted are not public record
they're not even they're not even in
government record you can't even search
for them so only a few people would know
it only only three people uhhuh and we
were like here you go and they were just
like eh and I'm like dude only three
people have like I don't even think it
was three people I think it was one one
one person and they're like me and I
said it just stops they don't care we
even had uh FBI was involved and they
said don't care kind of the the bomb the
fake bombs that were sent to us they
didn't care I'm like someone sent mock
bombs and to shank re weager or whatever
his name is no no and they sent that
robots to our to our studio and we were
like we have information on how this is
happening and they're like we don't care
and I'm like you guys had to come out
for this and they're like never called
us once never asked us didn't care and
so a lot of people actually started
posting like it's the feds doing it to
you and I'm like well I don't know about
all that but I can tell you they
certainly like that it's happening
because they're they're corrupt evil
lazy or combination of all of it can you
talk Tim you said you mentioned Civil
War are you saying that like there's
already one going on against the right
they just haven't recognized it yet well
fifth generational Warfare you can call
it whatever you want some people it
depends on your definition of Civil War
but if uh federal law enforcement is
expanded weaponized and being used to
Target political opponents you can call
it a soft coup I don't know you can call
whatever you want I mean look the the
the the the Biden doj is going after Joe
Biden 's rival like the federal
government under Joe Biden is arrest has
arrested and criminally charged his
chief political opponent yeah the
federal government is not supposed to
have an opinion about who the who which
you know which political party is
running the government like they're not
supposed to have a have a say they're
just supposed to say we reflect whatever
the
people they're supposed to be you know a
reflection of the will of the people not
they're not supposed to dictate what
people should think cool if they
renounced their party party affiliation
when they got into the federal
government oh that doesn't mean anything
it would just be nice to look at look
you can you can I think there's one
strong argument as to why we're not in a
civil war because there's only one side
fighting MH Republicans what what should
they be doing uh they should be filing
criminal charges at the state level uh
you you could have a small
District Ada file criminal charges start
an investigation over tons of stuff
related to Federal Finance uh
like at the state level so if there is a
state campaign happening in in in your
red State you can start looking into
donations given James O'Keefe uncovered
a lot of questionable practices in
donations James O'Keefe goes goes to
people's doors and says you made 10,000
donations you were making three
donations a day and they're like no I
wasn't where's a single Republican
prosecutor to be like okay it's time to
to launch an investigation of this they
don't do anything meanwhile you've got
the federal government
literally trying to put the front runner
for the Republican party in prison so
maybe it's not a civil war maybe it's
just I don't know a coup I agree that
there are legal ways to attempt to you
know Rectify but I'm kind of with you
that like the law has become so abused
in this country in the last 110 years
pretty much since the soft coup of the
Federal Reserve and these Jackal hide
jackal jackal Island dudes you know JP
Morgan and friends that it's like accept
it and just change the minds of the
people so that whoever has the control
of the mob is going to be good well
that's the thing I I I I think it's
important to mention that uh we're
winning and that it's because we've
focused on cultural issues and lesso
politics so while it is frustrating to
see Republicans not doing anything the
groundwork being laid by say rumble by I
mean Elon musos especially with buying x
with uh parallel economy this is
essentially Dan bun youo this is Rumble
this is several others launching a
financial transaction system which we
use for
timcast.net desperation mhm the only way
to stop Trump is to just cross the line
and try to have him
arrested that that precipitates their
their their their fall you know I I the
first that this whole parallel economy
thing got really really real for me was
this past week when uh the lady Ballers
trailer came out it's it looks like a it
looks like a Hollywood level production
movie right like it's it looks really
good the the the previews funny um I
don't know it's like we're finally
figuring things out how to make it
really work and take it to that highest
quality level I don't even I I who yes
but we should say who cares Hollywood
can go make their weird Marvel Marvels
that bombs worst worst Marvel movie ever
less than the Hulk which one is this the
new one that just came out the Marvel oh
oh the Marvel yeah yeah it it made less
money than the Hulk did and that was
considered to be like the black sheep of
the MCU and now the Marvels did worse
and I'm like you know they're losing
culturally
they're losing really really bad
actually you know what let's let's let's
let's jump to this story and we'll talk
about it we have this from the financial
review gen Z could be the most
conservative generation ever they go out
less have less sex and lose their
virginity later what is up with young
people and teenagers and there's there's
there's a couple questions about what
this really means so let me break it
down for you very simply
first the most conservative doesn't mean
that jenz as a monolith believes certain
things it could be that 30% are super
far left but 31% are super conservative
and then people in the middle or
whatever so now it's the most
conservative but what I think this
actually means is you have to when
you're talking about conservative versus
Progressive you have to look at the
relativity of the previous generations
if you took someone from 1650 and
compared them to Joe Biden Joe Biden
looks Progressive as they come despite
the fact that he's an old man or more
importantly like Chuck Grassley like
take like an actual Republican who's
considered a conservative compare him to
a dude from the 1600s and you're going
to be like the guy from the 1600s is
backwards and you know super far right
or whatever however they describe it so
when we're when we're asking whether not
someone's conservative the question is
are they more traditional or less
traditional by the previous generation
standards and the argument being made
here is that genzi is is less
traditional than the previous generation
standards indicating they've shifted
back towards Traditional Values in a way
we have not seen in a 100 years this we
saw this we saw this data back in 201 we
are seeing it repeated over and over and
over again that suggests while jenz
probably has similar politics to
Millennials the fact that on certain
areas they've moved more traditional
more conservative this suggests jenzi is
actually the most conservative by
movement not by politics I want to make
sure that's clear MH we are not saying
that j a 20-year-old has the same
politics says Chuck Grassley we're
saying that a 20-year-old has more
conservative views than a 35-year-old to
throw a wrench in this uh this says they
go out less have less sex and lose their
virginity later I'm sorry to tell you
guys the economy the inflation people
cannot afford to go out and because of
Tinder and crap single one wealthy guy
is getting like 10 women so those girls
aren't around to have sex with anymore
for those kids those guys those humans
right right right and and and that is a
good point based on that statement but
when you also look at what we brought up
uh previous
that jenzi actually uh is is aligned
with Boomers on the question of same-sex
marriage and the support for samesex
marriage has declined that actually
suggests politically Jen is more
conservative and I think this may be due
to liberals abort their kids and about
internet it just like ideas spread like
wildfire with internet so do
conservative ideas oh you know what's
crazy and I was just thinking I bet
liberals get pregnant way more than
conservatives do it's totally possible I
think I think absolutely true if conserv
if they got pregnant three times as much
but had twice as many abortions boom or
twice as much twice as many abortions
look at the point they're making about
uh having less sex means you're
conservative conservatives and
especially Christian conservatives very
religious people are waiting until
marriage meaning substantially less sex
and pregnancies but then they have those
kids whereas liberals they bang like
crazy more power to you but then they
get tons of abortions there there's
actually some new trends that are
troubling that I've seen that show that
they the teens are is having less sex
it's not because it's like the rise of
the incels right like they they watch
porn instead of having sex and I think
there's a real you know in Japan parents
hire uh like strippers and sex
counselors for their their young Sons
because they don't pursue women they
they view their computers as their
sexual gratification it's happening
everywhere though did you see Kim
Jong-un crying no Kim Jong-un cried
begging the women of North Korea to have
more babies wow and I'm like wait North
Korea like they don't have the internet
there how are they having less kids
there of all places they they aren't
subject to the same social pressures as
the west Western countries are what do
you think causes Baby Boom my theory is
that it's an optimism in the future
right so like we the big the big baby
boom we had what all these guys came
back from winning the war in World War
II there's a huge baby boom I think we
have a different problem now I think
that there's a real pessimism in the
future and there's like a malaise that
has taken over this country and that's
why you're seeing decreased fertility
rates cuz I have I have a lot of friends
that haven't had kids yet aren't married
and their number one thing is I don't
want to bring a kid in this world it's
so crazy and I and that that's always uh
stuck with me because I'm going the
exact opposite route I'm like no I need
more I need more kids to change the
world strongly feel like the I'm not
bringing kids into the world because the
world is terrible I feel like that's a
cope it's a c I really don't think
that's true and and I don't believe the
economy stuff either we have I've
mentioned this eight casinos within 2
hours drive from where we are right now
now you like these places can't exist
people are are dumping money and and
some people say well it's credit or it's
irresponsible I'm like yeah sure
whatever either way people are choosing
to use what money they have on other
things it's often said there you know
people are always like we're waiting for
the right time to have kids there is no
right time no right that's a myth it
never gets easier by the way it gets
harder it it so I'm I'm 37 we had number
six when I was
36 it was tough you're you're more tired
you don't have the energy
that you have when you're 23 or 19 I had
my first at 19 tons of energy I mean it
was still tough and challenging but it's
gotten harder and harder and more
difficult yeah I can afford it more but
it is way more taxing on your energy
levels and in stress we got we got
Americans are morbidly obese so it's not
food so what is it it it is interesting
and and remove it from from the United
States and look at North Korea North
Korea is having population problems and
we assume that they're starving but that
clearly food is not the issue when when
Kim Jong-un cries and begs his women to
have more babies it might be like a
collective Consciousness thing this is a
bit out there woo woo you would say but
I do think there's something colle the
collective Consciousness when like nine
people feel good and then the 10th guy
walks in the room he's he might start
feeling good too just CU he can feel the
energy like that that's Global that's in
the Schuman resonance in the in the
Earth's magnetic field I think that
there's some sort of communication but
like I went through when I was 26 with
this one girl we were talking about I
was like yeah I don't want to have kids
cuz what you were saying Terry I don't
want to bring them into this crap hell
hole but I knew that was kind of fake we
were saying it out loud but I in my head
I was like it's not really true though
but I did say I don't want to travel all
over the world like my job's traveling a
lot of it is it has been throughout the
years and I didn't want to leave him
behind when I went and traveled and I
don't want to be that Dad that wasn't
around like four days a week cuz I
wanted to tour I wanted to go tour and I
never ended up really touring but I
still want to go tour when I want to
tour but I I don't know it's it doesn't
but then the loneliness of just getting
on my computer and being like what
another one of these days like there's
more to life how is it I I think it's
just really interesting that North Korea
is experiencing this they they rule they
control culture with an iron fist so it
is interesting to see that's happening
all over the
place you know Russia when they Russia
did this huge experiment in the 1920s uh
to abolish the family and they were
really they were too successful where
they ended up having to reverse course
because people weren having kids anymore
so what they did was they I forget the
term for it but they like basically
honored mothers like if you were a
mother of x amount of kids you were
given like the ultimate worker title and
it was like the most glorious and
venerated position in the country and
they they ended up having to do a lot to
reverse it I think we're Americans kind
of chose it though in the Soviet Union
they liberalized everything they did uh
they made marriage a a 5minute
dissolution process uh they uh made you
raise your kids away from the home that
you couldn't even have your grandma or
it's happening but Americans like
actively chose it right like we we now
are doing this whole women's lib thing
which you know I don't really care if
women work but like why why do you want
you're going to work for someone right
you're going to serve someone why not
your family why not your kids like why
do you want to work for Jeff Bezos over
these little human beings that
absolutely love you and are will do
anything to get your affection in love I
just got to I got I got I got I can impy
it
dramatically why would a woman choose to
enter a pickle jar opening contest
against a man and I'm being as silly and
absurd with it as possible the joke
being of course women can't open pickle
jars some women of course can my point
is yeah men and women are different and
men do a lot of jobs that women would
not want to do specifically due to
physical differences like carrying
bodies out of burning buildings is a job
for a man why sorry dude I there there
are some Wom can do it but on average
overwhelmingly it's going to be a guy
who can lift a body and pull them to
safety out of a burning building why did
society decide women should start
competing with men in their role that
led to a massive decline in birth rates
well what was look I I had I don't think
I had that unique of an experience but
my great grandmother so I'm the eldest
of an El of el so I knew my my
great-grandmother was 60 when I was born
um
she was The Matriarch like no one messed
with her she was the boss like you
didn't want to be on her bad side you
couldn't really fool her I never really
grew up with this mindset that like
women were inferior to men like it was
never even a thing I actually always
thought that like I don't want to make
Grandma mad I don't want to make my mom
mad I don't want to make you know it was
just always but so like in my mind women
have always been elevated in our family
and I I don't think that that's that
strange for most of America I think most
people would defer and do what Their
great grand mother said or what their
mother said and so you have this weird
thing where women started fighting for
equality when they had the whole world
that someone tweeted I forget who it was
but it might have been pachy Keenan who
I'm a huge fan of but she said the
problem is is that when you Proclaim
that women can do every anything they
end up doing everything they're they're
they're the the the bread winner and the
Homemaker they you spend less time with
your kids you spend the weekends doing
all your chores and catching up on
everything and I don't know I like women
were elevated in society
and they were I don't know it's puzzling
the end result is simple the people who
have kids their ideals will persist
their genetics were will persist and the
people who don't won't it's it's just
that simple well you were talking about
roie Wade earlier and and how and I
think you're exactly right like the the
real issue with roie Wade is it didn't
allow the states to experiment we didn't
get to see how different uh abortion
limits in different states and and and
you know and what that would produce
everyone had legalized abortion up until
the moment of birth and that was that
and so now we actually have a situation
where we can see that the results of of
being a pro-life State and how that is
more beneficial to your I think the
report was 32,000 births attributed to
the overturning of roie Wade that's huge
that ain't happening in blue States no
so if we actually see population decline
reverse in red States due to actual
human reproduction blue States will
still keep declining and then they can
bring in all the non-citizens they want
to show up their numbers but all that
matters is do human beings have access
to abortion yes no if you don't you're
going to have way more kids that's just
it basic math y'all can make every
argument to factor in every variable but
still the the the overwhelming mass is
going to be people in California they
may increase their their their
population every year by 100,00 per se
but they're not having kids so it still
will just be people aging and then
passing on and then they've got to keep
at at at the bare minimum they're just
maintaining themselves in a treadmill
what if the illegal migrants have the
kids they also can have abortions too
nothing's baring illegal immigrants from
having abortions they don't seem I don't
know this is a generalization but I in
Mexico for instance it's much more
culturally uh acceptable to have large
families and lots of kids Planned
Parenthood tend to be in minority
neighborhoods and they target them
mercilessly with advertising and and PR
it's it's crazy you you may be right and
I have I have considered this that uh a
different culture and it's and we're not
talking about Mexico it's not these
these illegal illegal immigrants come
from all over the world uh many of them
are coming from South and Central
America they may be more religious and
less likely to get abortions but that
doesn't change the pressure system that
exists where you mentioned they're being
targeted you've got uh South Park did
that funny joke where uh South uh
Cartman is a teacher and he's telling
all the girl all the Latina girls to get
abortions and the black girls he's like
just cheat just get rid of the baby and
you can be rich do like what white
people do but white conservatives are
having kids
well here's the question then you
mentioned earlier the Soviet Union had
had given women like special benefits
for having kids and I've heard like some
countries lower tax burden up to like
100% if you have four kids you don't
have to pay any taxes at all uh so would
there be any value to doing that for
women that are illegal
immigrants in the United States I I I I
just don't I think as a matter of rules
you can't give benefits to illegal
immigrants I I you can't do any incen
for illegal immigration they're they're
breaking the law we have to control our
border but I I do think that we have to
do this for moms in America right they
it my wife works so hard and she I don't
know how she does it half the time
but it's it's almost like society looks
down on moms right like oh you're a
stay-at home Mom oh yeah that's way
harder than your joke of a job sending
press releases out for Google right like
as as some lowlevel person like being a
mom is a tough job and it's the most
important job in what world will you
ever have little you know your your the
people underneath you looking up to you
like children do to their mothers right
like you will never get that in the
workplace you die at you start a
successful business and you die you are
forgotten like immediately they move on
they find a replacement you don't do
that with your mom you don't do that
with your dad as long as they're good
you know what I mean but like I don't
know I'm kind of ranting now but I I
don't understand the misogyny in general
where it's coming from or why I mean
maybe it just I wasn't around it growing
up cuz I had similar to you like Ain
phenomenal mother like the family was so
legit and she was like if she said it it
happened like there was no denying her
Authority that was your experience too
yeah yeah it's coming from feminists
femin feminists want to uh so you get
feminists who want to be in masculine
roles and so they attack and attack and
attack the feminine role and now we live
in a society where the feminine role is
looked down upon it's
insulted and and they argue that they're
fighting Four Women I think that at the
root of all of these all of these people
these activists that are doing this I
don't think they came from Happy
households right and so what they grew
up with they end up spreading to
everyone else and they cause chaos and
dysfunction for all of us and it just
it's like a cancer it keeps spreading
and I
mean I don't know I my my the women in
my family Ruled The Roost and you know
if my wife were to say like you're not
doing this guess what I'm not doing
right like I defer to my wife on
everything she lets me lead most of the
time but at the end of the day they they
make the rules and if they come down
hard on something you're not doing it
it's not happening when I was like I
started making internet videos in 2006
and I was like 26 years old and there
was this girl I was like maybe I'll
start a family with this girl and then I
was like what would my life be like for
the next 15 years I'll just be making
internet videos of like me with my kids
what value is that going going to bring
to society and now I realize oh it'll
show people how to have a happy and
healthy family and that's then you
create it in one spot and it has
Rippling fractal effects it's not like I
need to go out there and impregnate
every woman to have a bunch of kids I I
need to show the world how to have a
family you know there was a really cool
Cheerios ad that came out years ago like
2014 and it was how to Dad and um it's
this Dad walking through the house and
how crazy it is being a dad and how fun
it is he really showed the beauty of of
being a father and need to make more
content like that let's jump to this
story as we talk about the potentials
for 2024 military.com says dozens of
troops suspected of advocating overthrow
of US Government Pentagon extremism
report says uh what they're likely
saying is that they found 183 people who
posted things like get woke go broke and
I don't want to serve a woke military
but you know let's read what they
actually say there's that dude that got
booted cuz he was a communist too a
couple years back oh yeah remember that
he had the hat and said communism will
win and an annual Pentagon report on
extremism within the ranks reveals that
78 service members were suspected of
advocating for the overthrow of the US
government and another 44 were suspected
of engaging or supporting terrorism the
report released Thursday by the defense
department Inspector General revealed
that in fiscal 2023 there were 183
allegations of extremism across all
branches of military broken down not
only into efforts to overthrow the
government and terrorism but also
advocating for widespread discrimination
or violence to achieve itical goals
widespread discrimination yo that sounds
like some guy might be like go broke I'm
like ah there you go he advocating for
discrimination because only their rules
apply he emailed like four people so it
was widespread he contacted enough 10 or
11 people there's three allegations or
what there's dozens 183 there's dozens
of people they've identified so how many
fed plants did it take to find them
faking like they were going to set up a
coup right that's what happened in
Michigan if there's 183 allegations and
they found 78 service members then you
know you do the math few hundred 105
that are feds it's got to be so the
allegation like well yeah but that's not
a real one cuz that guy was a Fed he was
just goating people into saying F
deception because technically people in
the military are already feds and he's
overthrowing the agents inside the
federal agency but advocating for the
overthrow of the government is that just
what counts is that is it saying that
Trump actually won in 20120 uh you know
it could be an FBI agent emailing a dude
like hey want to overthrow and then guys
like just puts a thumbs up emoji on this
on the question like it could be that he
agreed it's probably even more innocuous
than that it's like three dudes are
sitting in a room playing Call of Duty
and then the fat just goes you know it'
be cool if like like Trump actually got
rid of Biden right like yeah sure
whatever dude or they say nothing that's
it we got them they didn't say no they
just don't even respond to it he's like
well they didn't say no to it so that's
agreement I dude I'm thinking of the
business plot SM smidley Butler 500,000
troops about to March on Washington DC
like they're talking about 50 70 guys
you kidding me me no I think the bigger
story here is not that there's
extremists want over the government it's
that the US military is basically
weeding out anybody who believes in this
country and so what I see as being more
likely here is the troops they're
accusing of sedition or whatever or of
like they're essentially accusing people
of sedition are probably like regular
Americans who are like hey man you know
we got serious problems with corruption
Donald Trump tried to withdraw troops
from Syria and they blocked him yeah Joe
Biden's son's on an energy board in
Ukraine where we have troops what the
hell's going on and if you say things
like that they're they're G to get mad
about it they're gonna call you an
extremist they're gonna look look what
military.com they posted was his Patriot
front they posted a photo of patriot
front to refer to these US troops now
look don't get me wrong some of these
guys might be Communists too like Phil
brought up there was that one viral
story about the guy what was it he like
went to West Point yeah he was uh he
would would have been a a as a graduate
of West Point he would have been an
officer and he had a shirt that said
communism will win or no
in his hat and then he held his hat to
the camera yeah he held his hat and he
did the the fist up and you know so he's
still on Twitter he's very lowkey and uh
and stuff but I follow him they
discharged him yeah he got booted so I I
see what what's going on and uh uh in
the US with the woke left and I just
think there's 70 there like a 70%
overlap with Nazis and and and the left
I mean the hatred of Jews is absurd the
conspiracy theories the racial uh
segregationist policies the collectivist
action the use of symbols it's like
almost the same thing the whole of the
like World War II was the left fighting
the left and they drew America in it was
the Communists and the Nazis fighting
which is they're both statist both
collectivist and the United States is
based on liberal principles which put
the individual first and they drug us
into their BS European garbage War they
got FDR to go fascist he got rid of the
gold standard he basically made this
country super fascist all money there's
an argument that and I generally have a
bad a negative opinion of FDR but there
is an argument to be made that I've
heard people make that is compelling
that is FDR was existed in a time when
socialism was V socialism and and big
government was it was omnipresent it was
ascendant it was everywhere and the
policies that and the argument that that
people make Pro FDR is that the policies
that FDR put into place the the social
safety nets actually prevented the
United States from turning into an
actual socialist country they were you
know they were things that obviously
liberals and and libertarian minded
people don't approve of but the point
wasn't intended to get more power to the
government because they the they wanted
to get more power to the government but
it was to prevent the people from
turning the United States into a
socialist government now I'm not sure
that that the argument is compelling to
me I'm not sure that I buy it but I've
I've heard it and you know at least it's
it at least it's like well okay that
makes sense when you think of the
context of the the whole world the whole
Western World at least in the in the 30s
and and 40s you know it was like that
that was when you know big government
and stuff was really having its kind of
ha it yeah Great Depression 1929 and
then all these governments are reeling
all over the planet like how do we get
how do we come back from this Banker in
set like what did the bankers cause that
I don't really know but I'm sure I
wouldn't be surprised if the same guys
that built the Federal Reserve that
tried to overthrow FDR in 1933 with the
business plot that that made the Bankers
Trust in 1903 like these Bankers JP
Morgan Rockefeller Paul warberg all
these dudes if they were involved with
with with trying with causing the Great
Depression in order to buy the country
up right after that and maybe they
wanted to be fascism FDR was like no
it's going to be socialist those are the
conspiracy theories that wouldn't
surprise me at all because it was like
fascism or Socialism or die it was one
or the other like you either want
massive Central Co corporate Co-op or
you want I don't know what's hell the
other option is socialism social systems
but without the corporation arianism
like less less corporations centralized
control I I I you know these arguments
about left and right and you know
communist and fascist don't matter all
that much it's authoritarian versus
libertarian for the most part it's
centralized versus decentralized and so
whatever whatever they claim the far
right to be is meaningless because it
doesn't actually describe what their
concern is their concern is other and
then when we say farle it doesn't
actually actually describe for the most
part our concerns because the concern is
centralization of power among anybody
could be corporations it could be
government
officials well there you go I guess I
just you solved it thank you yeah you
hit the you got the 100 yeah man
centralization is no joke I mean it is
you can see the power of it in Mass
mobilization appeal but then you look at
Kim Jong-un sitting all alone in his his
palace with all the authority in the
world and the women aren't having sex
well not in the world just in just in
North Country can't make those girls get
pregnant no it's it's actually simple
because they want to be with with him oh
maybe that's right they're all saving
themselves hoping that one day you know
honestly that that could be a component
especially of of centralized
dictatorships with a cult of personality
there could be a lot of women hoping
that they get chosen so they want to be
pure and that results in a trend in
their culture there's also the
possibility I mean
allegedly if I understand correctly
there's a lot of starvation going on in
North Korea and if you can't keep
yourself alive because you can't get
enough food It's probably hard to get
pregnant too yeah if anyone that has a
girlfriend or a wife would know that if
she's hungry that's about that's about
where it ends right there I mean yeah
some if she's hungry you're not getting
laid that's true but I was more think
about the biological process of of
actually building the human being inside
the womb starts there but yeah you know
Snickers cuz she ain't the same when
she's hungry and you ain't getting none
you want yourself yeah but I don't know
going back to the military.com stuff
with the the claims about I mean it's a
sensationalist headline suspected of
advocating overthrow of US Government
probably is some dude on his computer
being like man this this Administration
sucks somebody should remove Joe Biden
whatever yeah whatever it is it's just
about it's we're going into an election
year you know there's there's less than
a year until the the election and the
the government wants the the media being
an in my opinion an arm of the
government they want people to be afraid
of Donald Trump you know the way they
were at have you have you seen those
videos where it's like Joe Scarboro yeah
like Trump's gonna make Rachel mattow
he's going to try and execute us like
Rachel Mano actually suggested Donald
Trump will will have them executed I see
so that's stuff freaks me out because
they project right like they project
what they're what they really want to do
and like you know they're imprisoning us
one you are 100% accurate it's freaky it
it freaks me out when they start talking
like that and accusing him of it yeah I
don't get well what what what what is
that the new poll do you think with
Democrats win in 2024 they'll start
executing their political
opponents I mean look there are there
are definitely people on both sides that
are at that point where they're like
look it's just time to start cutting
people up you know I'm sure scary I mean
yeah I think there's always people like
that but yeah but like the question is
if they are projecting and saying that
Donald Trump wants to execute them is
that a projection of them suggesting we
have to do it otherwise they'll do it to
us I mean that's where that stuff leads
the you get these videos we talked about
like Pearl Davis and and and the
manosphere stuff they you have all these
guys being like nope every man in the
world would cheat on their wives and
it's like you're just saying you
would you're saying you would you're
saying in your mind if you experienc
this you would cheat on your wife not
everyone is like you so when they scream
Donald Trump is going to do this stuff
to us what they're really saying is we'd
do it if we had the power and if they
get the power they'll do it to us
because they view that as the path
forward I strongly agree with that
sentiment people tend to believe other
people are going to do what they would
do given the circumstances why do they
think this about Donald Trump is it
because he said he wants revenge no it's
projection
a hint I don't think Trump said Revenge
he said retribution right retribution
yeah so the issue is the reason why
there are these guys that are advocating
this idea where if every guy was given
the opportunity to cheat on their wife
they would yeah I saw that one push the
button in their mind in their mind they
can't see a circumstance in which they
personally would feel differently they
can't empathize or comprehend another
person might be like no I would not do
that and it's so shocking the feeling in
them is so strong the desire to cheat on
their wives that they can't imagine any
other man could resist that urge to
cheat on their wives which is it's it's
it's insane because not only are you
talking about a guy not being able to
control whether you know how horn he is
to not Cheo his wife but that no guy has
the Integrity honor or force of will I
think part of that part of that with the
whole like people that are just like oh
you know they would it's because they've
never had the opportunity to like if
you're a guy that's like in a situation
where you get one girl and that's like
you you landed her and you don't you
know you don't get second looks very
much and and you're not particularly all
saying never found you know that you're
just like oh yeah I would totally
because well that's that's like I would
never have the opportunity you know
outside of this one particular situation
that I have and if I was presented with
the opportunity it would be such it's
such a rare thing I I don't feel like I
could control myself and say no if you
have options you're kind of like H I
don't want to mess M up the good thing
it's it's it's also suggesting that
these guys who are saying this never met
someone they truly loved maybe and so
they're just like these people don't
matter that much to me I would of course
break my word but I I'm not trying to
get into that conversation my point is
this feeling within people they cannot
imagine thoughts outside of their
perspective so when Rachel mat says
Trump will arrest and execute Us in her
mind she's thinking about how she would
feel with that power and in her mind she
would arrest and execute Donald Trump it
is projection something they believe
humans are capable because they're
capable of it when I'm trying to
empathize with someone that thinks
differently than me first thing I do is
I visualize them with a blank slate not
literally a blank slate but like there
is no emotions before I try and
visualize what they're feeling I have to
let go of what I'm feeling that's the
first step if you just try and feel what
they're feeling your your emotions are
already present so you have to blank
blank it you have to get rid of it and
then you can kind of start to think it
could be anything what they're going
through why do I think what I'm have to
say is is any valuable well let's talk
about how genen Z is feeling from The
Daily Mail younger Americans fearing
2024 election could spark a civil war
are preparing for disaster 40% of genz
have spent money on doomsday
preparations new survey fines and it was
uh 2,179 us adults in January to
February and they found
40% had bought uh prepping supplies and
the majority believe it's because uh uh
there may be civil rest or Civil War in
the next year I wonder what prepping
supplies counts as because if if they're
just like oh they bought a handgun and
that's prepping supplies I'm a little
leery about whether they're actually
interested in preparing for emergencies
but if they're just like w i i don't
think it's that simple I think it's uh
it's a they they were asked if they'
spent money preparing for
emergencies so it's likely going to be
flashlight change the batteries in my in
my my uh fire alarm yeah there's so many
I got a I got a a life straw we got a
bunch of them yeah we probably have like
50 downstairs I ordered a machete you
know like I got a knife I got a LIF
straw I got I got extra shoelaces just
have to go hunting buy blowout kits buy
turny kits in gauze so it seems like a
large portion are concerned but I do
think that uh the headline is a bit
misleading the reality is 40% of gen Z
has spent money on prep preparing for an
emergency now how many of them are are
doing it because they fear Civil War I
don't know if it's that much that's
actually not stated in the story but I
do think the fact that jenz has actually
considered buying things these are
people who claim to be broke can't
afford food can't afford to buy homes
are saying the Boomers ripped them off
and stole all the wealth and all that
stuff but they're going to spend money
preparing for disasters it says one of
two things one jenzi is as we already
mentioned before more conservative and
thinking longterm and that's all it
really means or in their world they are
seeing things that give them reason to
believe emergencies disasters and
potential conflict may be arising in the
future the reason why boomers are
probably less likely to do things like
this is because in their minds Civil War
is not possible but to gen Z Society is
already broken I mean these are these
are these are young people who are
teenagers in the first recession and
they're watching all that happen around
them Millennials I'd imagine would be in
a similar place or pot or or I wonder if
this suggests projection as to what they
think is going to happen in 2024 meaning
many gen Z people not all of them not
necessarily the plurality are far-left
are engaging in acts of violence every
day and so the reason they believe they
need to prepare for disasters is because
they might be the disaster so so I I
think your spot on I I think the only
way an actual like open Civil War
happens is if Republicans take back
power and then the left starts doing
activity no I don't think so you think
it could be done started by a right
winger I think it will a 99% chance be
started by a right winger I I I just I
don't know I I think that I just don't
see it I I think Mo all of the talk
about right-wing the right-wing starting
the Civil War I just think it's what
what are the hot Catalyst issues that
could lead to a Civil War in this
country Donald Trump getting
elected in in what way like you the
Democrats you think will go and Target
States and yeah I think well no I think
you'll see BLM and antifa steroids I
think that you will have they really do
believe that he is Hitler I mean they
have been brainwashed to believe that he
is I think maybe neolibs do but when
Trump got elected the first time we had
a large riot in DC and that was kind of
it and then it wasn't until uh the
summer of love that things got truly
truly bad it's possible that if Donald
Trump won in 2020 West Coast states
would have seceded from the Union as per
that Boston Globe report which could be
the Catalyst for a Civil War and so
that's a more direct formal however
Republicans are more likely in that
regard to just be like see you later so
what I actually see is abortion mhm
border security and um and and foreign
war I think like
antifa you know maybe would would try
and facilitate some kind of escalation
of conflict they believe they are
because they want to destroy the system
and burn it down but in terms of issues
that are affecting this country that
could lead to someone actually getting
organized and and calling for
conflict I feel like it's more likely to
come from someone on the right meaning
uh we've I've talked about Oklahoma and
Colorado sharing a border where
Oklahoma's permanent has has banned
abortion in all cases and Colorado has
allowed it up to the point of birth MH
that's the kind of you know oil and
water mixture happening right there on
the border that can result in major
conflict you've also got child sex
changes is it going to be a leftist Who
start who brings a bunch of guns and
opens fire on law enforcement and
government because a child was not able
to get a sex change or is it going to be
a father and a crew of his friends who
get their get armored vehicles drive
into California to rescue a child who
was captured or taken kidnapped by by
someone to give them a sanctuary
sexchange operation in the states yeah
and maybe that is what maybe the left
you know they're passing those laws in
Washington and Minnesota and California
that allow them to the state to kidnap
kids that end up making not even the
state third parties so uh I think I
think it could be Oregon I believe it's
Oregon uh a a random person could bring
a child from anywhere to that state for
a sex change the state will not go after
that person who
did maybe they're baiting maybe they're
trying to get someone provoked maybe but
my point is the the the left is is
playing this game where it's just the
destruction of the system all around
everyone that when they take
institutions they destroy it they wear
it like a skin suit if it is going to
escalate to a conflict it's already the
left the federal government the Biden
Administration that are targeting and
destroying things if it's going to
become a civil war it's going to be
because someone on the right did
something I I can kind of ID I guess I
guess we can real quick I guess we can
say it this way the left is already
engaged in the conflict mhm it's not a
civil war because only one side is
engaged in violence yeah if if so you
take the hypothetical that Trump got
elected again and then there were riots
again like there were last time for
whatever reason but last time I was like
where's the National Guard why is it
three days now on the third day I was
like what they haven't stopped these
rights so let's say the National Guard
does get called up this time and then
some nihilists in the crowd that are
rioting are like I'm going to die for
this cause they they want they have
fully given up and they're willing to
die they charge a police officer try and
grab his gun get shot yeah that kind of
thing I can see like crazy disillusion
nihilists that maybe are wearing all
black and they just run at Co like that
could then the the media will be like
cops Gunn down and you're like well gez
and then the media inflames I could see
like that but my real concern is the
power goes out the internet goes out and
then just dude show up at your house
with weapons and stuff I I just I think
the most likely scenario is essentially
that there is some small little thing uh
relatively small and the government says
we've uncovered a plot and now they
start rounding up people I think it's
much I think Democrats in power is much
more nazes right aren going to do what
you describe though I I I well yeah I
mean if you're antifa if you're actually
a militant group uh Trump is not going
to start rounding up leftists no he
won't I agree I agree I agree um but but
I think
the Democrats literally already are
already are and they're getting away
with it they're getting away with it
right and and there are January six
defendants who shut up an hour after the
riot walked up stairs with no barricades
no glass cops waved people and open the
doors and they were waving Little
American flags like what's going on here
and then they were like now you're an
insurrectionist and they're like huh we
just walking down the street we don't
know what's going on we weren't even
near anywhere here an hour ago doesn't
matter those people are already getting
locked up y so the Biden Administration
is already rounding up inoc Trump
supporting
Americans and they're and and they're
being raided every single day so this is
already happening in this country but
it's a one-sided Civil War right which
is why it's it's I would you can say
it's not a civil war mhm if people on
the right take up arms and start
resisting not Civil War now it's Civil
War where I think the appropriate path
is Donald Trump is on a path to Victory
we're winning culturally and so the last
thing we want is an escalation of
violence to legitimize the things that
the left is trying to do they want the
conflict because a civil war would allow
them to destroy the Constitution and
then override this country and March in
with boots uh where a lot of regular
people would just get on their knees and
say you know do whatever you want so if
Trump gets in and we actually start
arresting and removing these people and
have trials for them then that's the
victory I think if the culture is like
hateful it doesn't matter whoever gets
in is it's still going to happen if if
that it's like 1932 Germany like we have
an opportunity to change people's minds
before they adopt Nazism that's where
we're at right now yeah but the right
had the
people call the right useless because
they won't even file criminal charges
against criminals the the circumstance
in which Donald Trump takes power and
then starts actually arresting and
Prosecuting and and and like Rachel
matow psychotic statement executing
people is zero absolutely zero Trump did
nothing during the summer of Love riots
he kept tweeting what was he was
tweeting Law and Order that's all he was
doing well he so I have a friend who
told me he he was in the administration
but he told me that Trump wanted to do
the National Guard but he was advised
not to
because the military wouldn't do it like
they would not follow his orders and
that it would cause an even bigger
crisis to have military leaders then
Trump lost a long time ago no I yeah I'm
not saying but I don't I don't I don't
know if if that sounds a little bit
extreme if you if you instructed the
National Guard be deployed or whatever
because of mass riots they just go stand
on street corners but but but look at
Portland right like is or is the Oregon
National Guard actually going to go into
Portland and and bring Law and Order to
that City Donald Trump if that was the
the case if if if I was the president
and someone said if you call for law
enforcement to stop these rights they'll
disobey the orders and then it'll create
a constitutional crisis where the
president appears to have no Authority
I'd be like oh I'll get in the TV right
now let's roll let's roll baby let's
make sure everybody in Oregon hears me
say we want the violence in your
neighborhoods to stop and we are asking
law enforcement to uphold the law and
then if they refuse to do it then you
say okay you are you are you are a
lawless State and you are in
Insurrection mhm but they but but it's
it's fair that they wanted Trump to do
this to use the imagery and claim that
Trump was a dictator who was rolling in
tanks and all the stuff that doesn't
matter to me if Trump was unwilling to
shut down the riots out of fear of the
perception and all he was doing was
tweeting Law and Order then he was not
an effective president so I do think
what's likely going to happen is if
Trump gets elected is it just puts a
puts a dam in place the uh the Democrats
have already I mean the Clinton
foundation's gone I mean they're they're
bringing it back I guess their fingers
are their fingers are are crossed but if
Trump wins then this machine is is is is
done already with Kevin McCarthy losing
the speakership that's a billion dollars
in IUS that are just toilet paper so if
we keep this up culturally we're winning
if we if and if politically we take it
or even resist to a great degree it's
done I and and I think what they
desperately need is violence so again
back to the point about gen Zer is
concerned about this perhaps because
many of them are progressive and they
know what they are going to do mhm you
know it's kind of like a guy who buys
fire Insurance on his house and then a
day later his house burns down you're
like you were really concerned about
your house burning down yesterday and
then it burned down you know convenient
you asking question hey Jen zers you're
really concerned about an upcoming
disaster is there something going on in
your mind have you been marching in
protest right you get the point but who
knows yeah I wonder from just that
headline that Daily Mail headline if
it's actually conflated if there're is
conflated these people legitimately in
the things that I am afraid of a Civil
War and I have because of that I have
ordered or they just like they're just
assuming they were afraid of a civil war
no they're phrasing it that way to get
clicks but the reality is 40% of gen Z
prepared for an emergency a large
portion whatever that means it could be
10% it could be I'd imagine at least be
a double digits if you're saying a large
portion or more than that uh said they
feared Civil War but I'll tell you what
I actually think is very very likely I
think the most likely outcome is that
one year from now we are sitting in this
room saying we don't know who won insert
State we don't know who won Arizona and
Georgia yeah I think that's realistic
that the day of modern politics is O I
mean not you consider it over like we
can't just assume that a vote does it
now it's no longer that way anymore with
machines and computers tallying stuff
behind the scenes in secret like we need
to make the world the best we can make
it on our own and not have to appeal to
authorities like that's the whole
private sector the purpose of this
country so let's kick it into
overdrive yeah I mean we like that's
essentially the argument that like the
libertarian party's been making for in
30 years but the population really wants
to use the government to make other
people live the way that they want them
to like that that's that's really what
it boils down to like Democrats that
vote for Democrat policies they they're
really voting so that way they can
instill the policies that they prefer
and same thing for the for the
Republicans so the idea that you know
that that that we just need to empower
people and and not have government be
powerful that's the argument that you
know like I said that's the argument
Libertarians have been making for
forever and Republicans used to make you
know I think I think Goldwater was was
the guy that said uh Liberty in in or
extremism in pursuit of Liberty is no
Vice there are people in the US or most
people aren't really that interested in
Liberty the way that like you know the
way that we we hear people say they are
cuz you know it it just pans out in in
El every every and Libertarians believe
in Liberty but conservatives and
liberals do not yeah conservatives uh
conservative ideology entertains Liberty
to a greater degree than liberals do
which is really funny it's like
paradoxical yeah liberals today the
modern liberal is one of the most
cult-like you know political bodies
we've seen in a long time conservatives
however are like yo take these uh uh
check out these um what what what is the
website IDR Labs or whatever uh moral
foundations quiz based on Jonathan
research and these questions are gnarly
yeah one of them is like uh they ask you
on a scale of not okay so it's it's very
like it's what is the scale it's like
not okay somewhat okay not sure uh not
okay or it's like what am I saying
there's there's not okay at all a little
okay and then
there's back NE but there's there's five
degrees that's what I'm trying to say
and so you can say this is good it's
okay it's bad it's really bad and one of
the questions is a man makes a lifelike
doll of his niece for self-gratification
is that okay or not Libertarians are
like totally fine yeah and conservatives
are like no and Liberals are like I
don't know about that but maybe and so
Libertarians have one moral uh moral
frame moral Foundation this is funny
Liberty that's it they don't care about
fairness they don't care about anything
they care about you leave me alone I can
do whatever I want so long as you're not
hurting another person you can do
whatever you want and the argument is
hey this doll doesn't hurt anybody let
him mind his own business and I'm kind
of like yeah that's not okay but it
leads to more right like you okay you
allow this and then guess what you don't
just have that guy making it then he
turns it into a company and now you have
a whole pedophile industry of people
that are now fueling it and guess what
that pedophile industry that's making
these childlike sex dolls it's now a
billion dollar industry now being
investing it into changing the laws to a
lot of steps Beyond just the the that's
how it starts but the point the point is
not not there's no reason to talk about
that the most extreme behaviors the
point is Libertarians care only about
Liberty and if a society was based
purely on Liberty you would see very
extreme things happening all over the
place lots of drug abuse extreme drug
abuse blow libertarian mind like what
you're saying if you actually child
pornography the industry girls are being
solicited for that industry which is why
watching it is illegal because people
are being used but if you have an AI
that looks like a young girl and then
they start to go into haptic feedback VR
to have relations like it's not a sex
style it's an actual virtual image of a
real person the person used we're not
talking about any of that the convers
libertarian go down get be down with the
conversation is not even about
Libertarians it's about the question of
Liberty conservatives believe in Liberty
within their moral framework liberals
believe in Liberty within their moral
framework the liberal moral framework is
substantially more narrow than
conservatives and then true Libertarians
have a have an extremely expansive uh
idea of what matter what what is
disallowed morally so it is it it is not
like you can't just say we we could say
on a a relative scale of of liberal to
conservative in this country
conservatives believe in Liberty more
than liberals do I think conservative
party identifies with libertarianism
really in a lot of ways in a lot of ways
but there are a lot of things they would
not accept like parents telling their
kids to uh get sex changes or things
like that so clearly it's not there is a
moral line where where conservatives say
no you are not afraid to do this thing
and also there's a lot of things that
that were portraying here as permissive
uh that Libertarians believe whereas
there are a lot of libertar you there
are Libertarians that are pro-life you
know not all Libertarians are are
libertine Libertarians um there's an
argument that anything that would hurt a
child or you know actually that that's
those are constantly made anything that
would hurt a child uh is the same reason
why you can have a pro-life libertarian
because it's not that the government is
sticking its nose in it's that the
government if it if there is a
legitimate rule for government
protecting the life of an of an innocent
person is one of the things that would
be a legitimate rule so here here's what
I want to say about next year we're
going to have an election in some kind
of Television sense there's going to be
a there's going to be I'd imagine every
State's going to have a lawsuit I can't
I can't imagine I mean maybe the solid
blue and the solid red just don't
because there's no point any any state
considered a swing state it's going to
be jammed up in the courts you're going
to have state is coming out screaming
being like no way no way it's going to
get way more vocal when the media calls
you're going to you're going to have
different media Al I think it's very
likely you'll have like MSNBC say and
Arizona goes to Joe Biden and then
you're GNA have real clear politics say
and no uh Arizona is going to Donald
Trump because they're just projecting
who they think the winner is and the
races will be contested it'll be tight
there'll be uh judges ruling some sides
will say they don't one side will say no
that jud's ruling is void oh that's a
trump lawyer or that's a trump judge
it's going to be a mess yeah it's going
to be December and we're going to be
like well we think Trump won but the
media is reporting it might not be the
case we don't know I feel bad for people
that are heavily invested in politics
and I feel like those are the people
that should not have political power
because it's that's a cult that is a
cult worship game and the media is fully
manipulating it yep do not let that
make you emotional just make your best
stuff now is the time we make a band we
release next year in December when we're
sitting in this room and we're like we
don't know who the who the winner
actually is because different media
Outlets are reporting different
projections there's active lawsuits like
we saw in 2020 and we're going to be
sitting like I mean look what I'm
describing literally already happened in
2020 you had States in lawsuits Texas V
Pennsylvania na a national original
jurisdiction lawsuit and it was the
media reporting Biden one but the whole
thing was being contested and a bunch of
reports are coming about about coming up
about adjudication but the state
legislatures in in in the states where
it mattered were not holding press
conferences were not challenging these
these these results and they should have
been and that would have forced Mike
Pence's hand when it came to the
electoral vote count or uh the
certification process show this kind of
show is good and it'll probably be good
next year too because we don't like
punch at the system like we don't go
directly at it and to like try and ruin
it that's the big problem that a lot of
people in politics make is they'll go
right at it and angry and that's just
that'll lose you the game so you but
we're good at like encompassing it I
think just to let people know what's
going on but I think that you know
complaining is not the answer we got to
create something bigger I would like to
ruin it personally depend on how you're
into that because if it's a really bad
thing it should be stopped and it but it
should be changed not just ended like
not just ruined into smoking Ash I think
tell me what you want to turn it into
failure needs to happen man that's what
Ron Paul's been saying for failure need
to be possible a pile of smoking ass
ases is kind of what I want just $99,000
cheeseburgers that'd be so horrible what
we no talking about economic ruin no not
economic ruin talking about
the yeah the bureaucratic system the
revolving door policies the the lobbying
system all of it needs to be shut down
yeah the government the the the economy
that we have in the United States can
absolutely operate entirely independent
of the government the government does
not we do not need the government
to have an an economy at all period in
fact the the when you argue against the
the Federal Reserve and and when you're
talking about the you know the creature
from Jackal Island and stuff the the
argument you're essentially making is
keep the government out of the banking
industry because that's the first thing
the government does to get into the
economy you know so if you're if you
want to have government if you want to
get rid of the Federal Reserve you're
you're by the very nature of the
argument arguing to keep the government
out of the economy I I yeah I I think
the government needs to enforce fairness
I think the problem with the FED Reserve
is that they're doing price controls on
borrowing money on the on on the value
of money right like there I think Tim
like you were pointing out that
conservatives support Liberty within
their moral framework and Liberals are
the same way I think that's right but I
think that the difference is is that I
view myself as a conservative or America
first guy I want I want the laws to
reflect the basic foundations of
morality you can't kill you can't steal
you break up monopolies when they get
too powerful and have too much control
over people how do you get to how do you
get to breaking up monopolies uh from
basic morality well if someone has the
market cornered and they're able to jack
up prices unfairly and they can really
corporations should not private
corporations should not have more power
than the government nothing right but
but it's that I think the government is
actually causing these problems I no I
agree I I totally agree I think
government's doing everything it
shouldn't and nothing of what it should
so like that we have a liberalized
government so I want basic things no sex
changes for kids right limit abortion to
something that's reasonable protect The
Unborn uh No Stealing no fraud you know
all of that the left on the other hand
they don't believe in any of the
foundation the basic morality and
foundations of it they want to control
every other aspect of your life so it's
like yeah get on unlimited abortions
have free sex but guess what now we own
you now we get get with all your income
we get to control every other aspect of
your life I think that's the I think
that's the big difference and so I think
it's much better to start with the
basics uh I I don't like the Federal
Reserve because they price control the
money uh but you it it would be it is
nice to have like a banking system that
all works and Mak sense now the question
is maybe it's just not possible I love
that you brought up breaking up
monopolies if that's like your number
three thing you felt like the government
should be
doing behind what were the other two in
hands whatever they were no killing No
Stealing no killing No Stealing break up
monopolies breaking up monopolies is a
huge part of it like alphabet that owns
Google that owns YouTube is like
massively monop I mean you could argue
it's monopolized social media they buy
up upstarts that are that are threats to
them that could disrupt them and then
just kill it and then but the problem is
like Vanguard Black Rock and State
Street aren't American they're not the
American government can't like stop it
they're Global corporations so I don't
know how antitrust would work in the
Modern Age with they've got some ties
there's always some leverage that we
would have over there I mean we're we
still have some say over things how how
are Vanguard and black rock like what
are they a monopoly of uh ownership of
Corporations I don't know I would I
don't know if I would
consider uh them monopolies necessarily
but they can't be if they are they can't
be well multinational monopolies are
concerning I should
for it to be a monopoly it has to be
like one industry that they control 20%
of every industry that's how they get
away with not seeming like monopolies
how about something like if your assets
exceed the a certain certain number or
or something like that right if you if
you're if if the value of your company
exceeds that of several nation states
then there's going to be some
restrictions put if you and all of your
subsidiary companies including all your
personal wealth and personal wealth of
those that you could argue are invested
in your company if they have 1% of the
company 1% of nobody that that has
significant wealth is has it personally
I mean look at Elon Musk is the richest
man in the world but the reason he's
rich is because he owns all the rockets
at at at SpaceX and he owns all the
Tesla cars that they haven't sold yet
and all the the ma he can only he can
only cash out a certain amount of money
and stock but I mean likez if I owned 1%
of Black Rock and I also had one and I
also owned another company worth a 100
million dollars you'd have to take that
company into account in the value of
Black Rock now because I'm a part owner
in it so just be my personal it would be
my corporate wealth as well but value is
nebulous like value doesn't mean
anything they're so entangled in in
other corporations value that it's hard
to like show like that's a monopoly on
paper but it is it feels like it or
triopoly I don't know what you would
call it what what Phil is saying is that
you're talking about perceived value not
actual value you're talking about
imaginary wealth numbers yeah it's
unrealized in what way what's it's it's
unrealized because you're it hasn't sold
so if you have something that's worth
$10 right like like mines let's say they
own the mines it's untangle Val like
what are those mines worth whatever you
can get out of the ground we don't know
yet you can that kind of stuff there's
there's estimates that when you you you
can look at a mine or at least people in
the mining business can look at a mine
and they can say well we estimate that
there's x amount of of value here you
know from from they'll do core samples
they'll do test digs and stuff and they
say oh you know we can we can guess that
it's about x amount of dollars per yard
that you can actually get out of this
and it'll cost x amount of dollars to
process the the yard of material so
you're they'll they'll they can actually
do that kind of profit and the same
thing with like oil companies and stuff
they can they can look at what they
figure an oil field is worth and stuff
so for the most part when you're talking
about you know that kind of industry
like when you're whether it be mining or
or you know oil oil stuff that's the
kind of stuff that we're we're at least
referencing now um in this context when
you talk about that kind of stuff
there's very Advanced there's entire
Industries built around just projecting
what you can get out of a certain
Endeavor whether it be you know an oil
field or or a mine or whatever so the
idea that that you couldn't tell what
the value is that's not quite yeah true
like add Revenue you based on last
year's numbers next year's numbers yeah
that kind of stuff is like we know that
like all it remains we know generally
what our our publishing checks are going
to be because they're about you know we
get
similar spins every month if we don't
put anything new out and stuff so it's
just that when you say Monopoly I'm not
sure what you're actually talking about
because it just sounds like the more you
talk about it it just sounds like having
the government tell people what they can
do with their check out these weird
numbers black rocks net worth as of
November of 2023 its net worth for the
company is 1 106 billion that's all they
worth how much
the N worth of the company how much
money they move around over9 trillion a
year that's so they're worth aund 1%
less than
one they're worth that's they're worth a
100 billion but they move 9 trillion
around every year so they're worth 9
trillion they can control that money
they're not wor what is money it's your
ability to use you are wrong a 9 million
under management so like value and money
are not the same thing you understand
that right I money is nothing with
without value right correct yes correct
so and so they're they're moving the
value around so they control the
valueone unless your money is like a
silver coin and then it's only if they
want to say silver is worth anything is
it become worth money bus it's not they
value value exists in the confidence of
the people hopefully yeah hopefully hope
it
does their whole business model is to
manage other people's money so the the
trillions of dollars that you're looking
at that they're managing that's other
people's money yeah like it's like you
don't give him your money and the
bank if I had the ability to give all
you guys money and but I'm like I'm only
worth a couple hundred bucks but I can
give you 10 million if you please me who
controls the money that's not your money
to give or it's not their money to give
away exactly technically it's not but
they still monopolize the ability to
move around it's not it's not
monopolizing people are going to them
with their money saying I trust your
expertise in this in this field to
manage this money so I'm giving you my
money your job is to make my money make
more money some people are going to them
other people are just it's just being
taken and given to them they don't even
know they don't know what black rock is
what do what is that what that they have
a on the market the sentence that you
just said what does that mean some
people go into a business they work 9
to5 they give money to their 41k they
don't know where it's going and that
means the person who manages the 401ks
for the companies has decided that one
of the Investments they're making is
going to be black rock and a person
takes money and brings it to Black Rock
and says you manage this so I I buy ETFs
like every week I don't know what the
individual uh funds in inside the ETF
there like who's managing what and stuff
I just know that the ETF has the
products that I'm looking to invest in
so I just buy that ETF people that give
their money to Black Rock they go to
black or to Vanguard or whatever they go
to these companies because they're like
hey I've got a big watt of cash and you
guys produce good returns so I want you
to take my money and produce good
Returns the whole argument against ESG
and and when it comes to the context of
Black Rock and Vanguard is they're
they're mismanaging people's money and
so the are the the actionable situation
is people give money to Black Rock and
they're supposed to take that money and
make it make more money but
ESG is not a the the foundation of ESG
is not make profit it's to make make
these socially
responsible uh socially responsible
decisions so that means that it might
cost money and if if you as a fund
manager are mismanaging people's money
they give it to you you're supposed to
make more money for them but instead of
putting it into something that is going
to produce a profit you're putting it
into something that is ESG compliant and
you're losing money you are not doing
your fiduciary responsibility to the
people that have given you money to
manage so that mean puts you in an
actionable position that means that
you're in a position where you can get
get sued by people but that's true and
they should be able to in a
multinational Court I mean they're based
in New York City black rock is but then
what happens when the government gets
involved and starts saying this place is
ESG so it's not up to Black Rock whether
or not the money's uh going to lose them
money because it the system's already
ESG now we've declared I don't well the
ESG is where their ESG is where Black
Rock decides to invest that money that
they're given the government shouldn't
be involed you know I'll table this talk
for now we got to talk to R it cuz if
anyone's fighting against the Black Rock
Monopoly it's Viv with strive his
company it's another index that you can
put your money in so there are other
ways right let's go to super chats if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
like it that's the most powerful way to
help and head over to
timcast.net comes from a member so it's
a member chat Stephen says says what's
up the show thanks for thanks for
chatting RJ McDougle with the first
Super Chat wins today's prize of Honor
says yo well there you go Josh bur says
hey Tim and team the San Francisco
tourist ads remind me of a video called
hastily made Cleveland tourist video I
think we should make one for
California well okay kth Swiss dick
Durban is a Richard haha is his name
actually Richard Durban yeah yeah dick
Durban yeah Durban was a slang ter back
where in Illinois because of him deran
yeah what did it mean what do you think
what yeah yeah it was a
verb so if a woman was yeah it was a
verb right it's really funny because we
were like teenagers but to derb meant
something like she's dering you know
what I mean and it's because of him and
because how much we hate politicians so
just someone thought it was funny it's
good you know there you go 4Runner C
says Gretchen Whitmer is going to run
for president she already has Democrat
funding lined up I hope she does she
can't win she's like Hillary Clinton I
hope she can't win well she she can't
like it's remarkable that in 2016 if
they chose any other Democrat Donald
Trump would not have
won I just don't Trump trump it's like
Hillary Clinton was the person for Trump
to beat really it's just yeah Hillary
Clinton was uniquely unlikable that's
right still is and so is gret and
Whitman oh yeah
yeah Raymond g Stanley Jr says lumer
calling Massie and anti-semite Is Pusha
crazy yeah uh uh Massie tweeted out what
is it it's the Drake meme and it's like
American patriotism he's like no it's
like Zionism he's like yes and then
Laura lommer said that he was being
anti-semitic because Congress is
fighting Hamas but I'm like I don't
think he's being critical of trying to
fight terrorism right I think he's
pointing out that a southern border is
porous and the and members of Congress
are more concerned with a foreign
country Chuck Schumer complained at him
for that tweet and then he had a pretty
sassy comeback
too I forget exactly what he said and I
don't have it in front of me but uh
something about about uh Schumer not
caring about the Border or caring about
the you know caring about Israel more
than caring about the border so it was
pretty good Jacob parody says apparently
the Democrat Senators blocked a subpoena
proposed by Republicans to view
Epstein's flight logs it was yaho news a
few days ago I well assuming that's true
it's because they're probably on those
flight logs so you know there you go
James Eaton says time is precious call
your parents
absolutely what do we
got hidden Zephyr says hey Phil just saw
that you and the guys will be a be a
Sonic temple in seabus yes you'll be at
Sonic Temple Sonic Temple yeah in what's
seabus uh C Columbus OH Columbus columus
can't wait see you guys Memorial Day
Weekend rock on it'll be sick Memorial
Day weekend when is that is that may may
that's yeah right
on graay says don't break the UFO Phil
or Ian glad you guys are here but didn't
break didn't break stuff LOL all right
I'm going try and fix it I didn't touch
it I have to let reset well it's cuz you
keep hitting the plug yeah you're not
you're knocking theug here my my knee is
right underneath the cord so that's a
little challenging have you considered
not hitting the CL made for about a year
and a half actually thinker for Life
says Tim have you considered closed Tim
Horton's Coffee and donut shops what is
a closed Tim what does that mean it
means they they're not around or they
shut their doors they're out of business
have we considered closed Tim Horton's
coffee and donut shops specifically
there's a really nice one in Grand Ledge
where redon was Oh you mean to reopen
yeah take the location oh I mean we're
not doing like yeah we're not going to
be it's going to be it's going to
there's not so there's there's there's a
lot I can't say but our plan isn't to be
directly involved in these things it's
to
decentralize but we'll have some degree
of involvement it'll just be light it'll
be more like a weak federal system where
the rights are retained by the
individual locations to to you know and
one thing we really want for all the
locations is local and americanmade
goods and Furniture MH so when you're
looking at Big franchises like Starbucks
they have everything's the same n we
don't want to do that the coffee will be
the same but I really do think it would
be great if you went to a coffee shop
and it was like when we serve food it's
from a local Farm it's real American
food and it's brought in in the morning
and then it's gone by the by the
afternoon and we don't get any more
until tomorrow you know I I I I don't
like preservatives we we've been talking
a lot about
bread and uh and gluten and it's funny
cuz we got these spin drift drinks right
and there's this G symbol on it and I'm
like well what does that mean I saw this
on some like um chocolate bar or
whatever and that it I bought a
chocolate bar that was like praline or
something and it's got this symbol it's
the gluten-free certification and I'm
like why is this on my my self assume
that yeah I know I they put bread in
this but I guess okay whatever and um
yeah anyway we started talking about
bread and you know the suggestion and
the Rumor for a lot of people is that
it's not the bread it's the chemicals
they put in the bread the bleaching
process and the preservatives that are
causing people to have all these
digestive issues and joint problems and
they just assume it's the bread because
the bread is what they eat when they get
the symptom but it's really something in
the bread yep if you get organic flour
and make your own bread you'll notice it
goes through like water I mean not
literally but it's compared to regular
bread with potassium bromate or that's
sprayed with glyphosate before Harvest
for desicant it's noticeably awesome
Ginger mcisaac says look out for a 1099c
cancellation of debt form if you don't
get it report it you will get a cp2000
letter for underreported income about 18
months later I just explained an extra
$3,500 tax bill assessed for this reason
yeah so all these people are getting
their their their college loans forgiven
they they likely will receive a
cancellation of debt form which is
income they're gonna have to fill papw
that would piss piss off Biden's voters
so bad it's like 4D chess like I
couldn't afford it last year what makes
you think I can afford the taxes on it
this year that's insane yeah cam girl
Luna says Tim you don't think Dems are
telling people to abort they literally
are remember that comedian telling
everyone to get abortions for example
yeah wasn't that Michelle wolf or
something she was like you get an
abortion and you get an abortion and it
was just like you are a dangerously
psychotic regets that think she regrets
that no oh wow yeah I don't know Lena
Dunham said she wished she got an
abortion but the funny thing is she's
not she doesn't have a kid so like it'd
be really bad if you had a kid you like
I wish I had an abortion it's another
thing when you don't have a kid and you
say you wish I had an abortion because
then she's implying she wants to get
pregnant so that she can just have one
for no reason it's psychotic it's it's
so mentally ill or so crazy and it's
death death is not something to joke
about
no no say love
V what do we have what do we have 19th
Shadow says you are correct Terry I am
miserable I am borderline depressed
however I will still vote for a better
tomorrow is that in reference to not
having kids or something I don't know
but I I do think that it's important
like I like that Trump is saying that
he's our retribution but big butt you
got to have a plan like you people have
to have something they're going to vote
for and maybe there's a good group of us
that want retribution but also we got to
fix some stuff too there's some major
problems Ryan Sergeant says it's easy
Joe has an unexpected Medical event DNC
throws up any semi-popular candidate
yeah but if they want to win you need
someone pushing and creating a narrative
right now like the idea that we are like
what is the Iowa is is a month away
right six weeks a month away wow yeah
January five weeks January 15th I think
yep Ronda said he's gonna win what do
you think his team on no it's not even
close yo we really but what hey hey man
he just what if he does you're going to
be like well yeah I'll be shocked I will
be shocked I you know I will be totally
shocked he just did Peterson's uh
podcast and it was all just Peterson
asking personal questions about Ronda
santis and it was not compelling you
know look I think the daily wire guys
are really really for DeSantis I don't
blame him I I I think there's a really
great argument for Ona santis but his
campaign has just been apocalyptically
bad you need Charisma yeah it's not even
about Charisma the dude could in a
basement if his campaign was being run
properly but just like attack you know
look going online and having your your
your PR staff attack people is a sure
fireway to lose yeah Will Chamberlain
handles it masterfully calm reasonable
and respectful responses to people who
are angry with him and I'm like they
should have put will in charge of the
campaign oh my gosh it would have been
so good yeah because a lot of what's
happening is Bruce Switz Master troll
Laura ler how do I describe Laura she is
the the most there's no one who supports
Trump more than her and she is vicious
when she when she goes for a story she's
coming at you with everything she's got
she's like a red witch that's not a
bad she's a fire fire Mage fire magician
like consider a witch like in the woods
you know me you mean like a Red Mage
from final Fant like a Red Mage she's
like a fire Mage she's got that fire
intensity the way you you counter this
is not by trying to imitate it because
you canot Rhonda santz has no one no one
as passionate as Laura lommer and no one
as as masterfully trolling as Alex BR
but the thing is Alex and Laura are
they're mimicking Trump himself so
that's part of it too they're they're
raising up to his level of trollness and
like Dan santis doesn't have that so
there's no level it it becomes awkward
if you try and be a troll and DeSantis
is he's like a a logical book smart gu
Laura is like figurative sidearm for
Donald Trump like Laura is not like
Trump you know Donald Trump is
boisterous confident very very funny
Laura lummer is the tip of a spear and
and no one supports Trump more than her
Alex brtz is tactful he's a strategist
and he knows how to troll so what
happens is that STIs people get whipped
up into a frenzy and respond enraged but
it's like anybody who's ever heard like
the old kung fu Masters about not
getting angry when you're in a fight
because it clouds your judgment that's
exactly what they did they knew that
when they were engaging in this fight
they're like I'm going to taunt my
opponent until they lose control and
then I'm going to dance around the
octagon and they're going to fumble and
and just swing and miss and burn out all
their energy that's what happened will
is the guy who has responded masterfully
but they didn't utilize them the
campaign is miserable it's unfortunate
really but to to the Jordan Peterson
thing I don't think we've gotten an
actual tough interview with Ronda santis
except for Patrick B David did pretty
well especially with the boots that's I
think it's as best as we're going to get
okay so I I don't look I think it's
hilarious that pbd brought the boots out
and stuff I don't know if that qualifies
as a serious interview though because of
the
boots has has anyone asked as sandis
about his campaign I mean this is a huge
talking point where everyone saying his
campaign is being mismanaged and he
won't fire these people I don't I don't
know how he didn't fire Christina pasa
that's who should have fired like right
away as she was the the Lynch pin and
all that it seemed like I think I I I'll
I said it before I'll say it again uh I
I don't remember was it Bruce Switz or
was it was it Bruce wtz put out the
photo with her knees were photoshopped
to be red like make it was Alex was know
that's funny if it was though I know a
photo was released showing her with a
bunch of people someone used Photoshop
to make her knees look like they were
read from being on the carpet and I
think that broker cuz it was around that
time she went from encouraging and
Cooperative with all of the people who
are in this space to instantly just
anyone who dare say anything about Ron
she is going to just attack relentlessly
along with all of her staff and these
other influencers it was like a switch
was flicked I think I think that broke
her you know she was running this
campaign we we we had talked to her
before like our people had asked her to
come on she said yes we is really cool
and then that moment happened and then
all of a sudden she's just screaming at
the top of her lungs and bashing her
face into the wall like like a lunatic
and and that's what it's been ever since
to have that kind of vanity in politics
is like yo you're going to get made fun
of and then you're going to be up
against Vladimir Putin's chief of staff
and like how are you going to handle
that when they when the real stuff's on
the table and not it's not about your
looks anymore I don't trust her I didn't
trust it their campaign was terrible all
right we'll grab some more we've got uh
William ubis is that how you pronounce
it disabled vet recently unemployed
still trying to reach giv and go goal to
get car fixed needed to find a job and
see my son for the holidays please
donate give send go it's a gbb 35 good
luck sir good luck on this Christmas
perhaps uh uh some people will will gift
you uh uh for the holiday season so you
can see your kid that's uh gbb 35 on GI
and go oh Christ Mass it means more
Christ I like it Christ Mass yeah
christas
misto Feliz now done all right we got
waffle Sensei says I don't know exactly
what will happen in the next year I see
them locking up Trump maybe bout removal
Biden drops out potentially for Nome but
even if we lose this election we are
still winning the culture and the future
that's the interesting thing that the
only option they're really going to have
is they have to win and they have to
start locking everyone up they got to
lock up Ian they got to lock up me they
got to lock up Terry Phil you're cool
but they'll they'll make you write songs
that are in support of them not going to
like I think this is like it's people
are realizing how how unimportant
politics is like it's never been part of
my life that big if my friend voted for
whoever we'd be like oh you voted for
that guy okay I voted for the other guy
let's go play cards and like we're back
to that we're back to like real life
where you make life good or no one does
but we are we still there we never left
right so the way I describe it is you've
got the left and the right these two
like overlapping balls in a vend diagram
and then on the left this tumor started
to grow and then it got bigger and
bigger and then eventually just SCH
slopped off onto the ground and that's
the left and the left and right still
there I don't I like if I were to have a
conversation with Ben Shapiro we'd be
like here's what I disagree on well
here's what I disagree on like oh
interesting who are you voting for I'm
voting for him I'm I'm voting for him
like oh wow we shake hands we'd leave
that still exists I can still sit down
with Glenn Beck as someone who leans
more to the left than he does and we can
laugh and make jokes and we can talk
about who you think should should win
and why and then once we're done we'll
be well good luck to you man I I I hope
you you get the vote I guess there is it
is a bit more intense and politics are a
little more important because of the
economy because of the inflation is is
like people were telling me for the last
25 years yo the American Empire is going
to end the American Empire is coming to
an end just so you know and it seemed so
like fantasy reality like okay I believe
you but I don't see it I can't see it
until it happens and now we're like okay
Mass inflation this is sort of how it
happens wow look at this is too busy
trolling says I got demoted from
Sergeant for posting Donald Trump make
our unit great again also letting us
grow beards will not solve the retention
problem I guarantee it is that what
they're doing
Maybe he can grow beards now I heard
that there was like something that
happened a while ago they said it was
racist to make uh people in the military
shave because uh black people have
different shaving issues and they get
ingrown hair or something some some it
was actually some leftist activists were
complaining about this I think it was
like occup it's supposed to be for the
solders own safety I think so you don't
get your face grabbed in a in a melee no
I mean argument it's from uh it comes
initially from like wearing uh gas mask
when it was important but they said it
doesn't really matter anymore but I
don't know now it's all about like
tradition Etc Phil probably talk you
probably know more of that than I do
Phil well I mean it was because gas
masks and stuff like that and then like
when when they allowed like when SS
became more prevalent in in the US uh
siks and and Muslims can't shave or
they're not supposed to shave for their
religion so that became a thing that the
military started to take into account so
there are I believe there are if you're
a seek you can and you're in the Marine
Corps you can wear a uh a I forget
turban the turban okay yeah you can wear
a turban uh your dress uniform or your
facial hair whatsoever but if they get
gassed they just don't they just MK
still works MK still fits it's not it's
not about that anymore it's the the
connection is still fine so yeah and and
I mean most of the gas stuff that people
worry about now is CS gas I mean exactly
if you're if you're going into a place
where the military thinks that they that
you might have an issue with actual like
nerve gas or something they would
probably be like look guys you don't
have to shave uh but you're going to die
if you don't you know so you probably
should all right Paul tascal says re
swatting no such thing as private
information everything is publicly
available if you know where to look
there are a few holes you need to plug
reach out I'll show you I used to find
people when I was a lawyer uh I see what
you're saying but I disagree there
absolutely is private information and I
will stress the levels that we went to
protect certain information is absurd
and I'll keep it simple there absolutely
our ways of protecting information and
making and and guaranteeing it nobody
finds it like I I can already tell you
this um people did this in Seattle yagi
antennas outside your house which allow
to uh so you you can get uh what is what
is something reasonable with a decent
yagi like a kilometer range yeah so yagi
are directional Wi-Fi antennas you point
it out your window you can't see because
it's in the building it's
aimed and we're talking about someone on
a Hill pointing it down and they're
getting Starbucks Wi-Fi from like a
kilometer away yet you're not going to
find that person they're they're using
airga computers with no information that
were recycled numerous times the
argument could be that well we traced
where where n these are people who built
random components spoofed the
information using custom operating
systems or using things like Tails OS so
they've really jammed up how you can
track it down and even if you were to
figure out the machine they were using
based on the machine's information it
was giving out you still wouldn't know
how they connected the Wi-Fi you'd know
that within a certain range okay maybe
within a kilometer you start searching
but they could have they could have lit
that computer on fire and it's
completely gone as for like properties
and things like this oh come on it's so
simple someone else buys a property and
they buy it under a trust so the
benefactor isn't related to you there's
no way to search for that person if you
don't know what their name is so we're
not talking about like banking
information or credit card information
which can be found we're saying
something like imagine a guy wants to be
able to stay in a house so someone else
is listed as a benefactor on a trust
which owns the property and it is in no
way connected to the other person and
this is a random person from from
another state or a corporation from
another state which is a subsidiary of
another Corporation and then it never
traces back to the original person who's
intending on living there look how easy
it is to hide ownership of assets Black
Rock how they I'm not talking about
ownership because that would be a tax
issue I'm saying somebody wants to live
in a house and have it obscured then a
random third party is the benefactor on
a trust that owns a property and the
trust is based from out of state and so
how do you know to search for John Doe
if you're looking for Ian Crossland you
would not it's impossible how do you if
you're the owner of the house how do you
guarantee that you still own the house
if TR I'm not talking about ownership
I'm talking about obis skating your
residency so you are living in a house
that the only way they could probably
find it would be by physically stalking
you but if we're if if that's not the
issue and we're talking about someone
out of state getting access to
information then we're talking about
someone just generally leaking
information otherwise again like a trust
is formed in state a the benefactor is
person B the the I'm sorry the
beneficiary the trust owns the property
and then you Ian are staying in that
property and you know paying rent or
something in cash or maybe you're not
paying rent maybe just you're you're
staying there how would the swatter know
to loc to to search for person b as the
benefit to or the or the trust's name
they could make guesses and the person
lives in this area look for a property
owned by a trust uh and then it gets
even easier now you it's bought in in a
in a third party's name who owns the
property and let you stay there and they
don't know you know that third party and
don't even know what even name to look
for do you think the mail the USPS has
their mailing list that they sell you
know companies can sell their mailing
list can can someone get a hold of that
like the address in of every American
citizen with a house I wonder if
avilable they they used to do that in
the phone book The White Pages yeah I
mean pages so uh in terms of our
property that got swatted we uh I won't
explain how we did it it wasn't the way
I just explained but there there are
ways to buy property to have the
information
protected somehow the swatters got
access to this information which was
only available to three people and uh I
don't want to say more than that for
security reasons and so we went and said
hey we can rule out how this happened
and they were just like man you know as
a brief aside it like the whole
encryption era of like having protected
data I was talking to this computer
scientist he's like well youo Quantum
encryption is
broken they're going to undo all the
past 20 years of encryption and
everything all your emails everything is
going to be public of all the people
it's going to be like a war hack like
anyway I don't want to derail too much
just a a mind-blowing thing to think
well my friends if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share the
show with all your friends if you really
do like it because and just think about
it if every single person who who
watched this show shared it we would be
the biggest show in the world because
that's we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people sharing every single
night to their thousand plus friends or
whatever but uh go to
timcast.net
Clips we're putting up because we're
we're launching the new show the boonies
we are investing several million
dollarss into the largest private skate
facility probably on the East Coast it's
going to be epic we're having a bunch of
pro skateboarders come out and other pro
athletes a lot of work is being done
here several videos of already been
released and we're starting slow but
we're just starting construction is
beginning soon we just uh signed the
deal to begin one portion of the park so
it's going to be amazing and uh uh check
that out uh you can follow me on
Instagram at timcast Terry do you want
to shout anything out you know uh thanks
so much for having me coming on um we
got this huge Gala it's basically sold
out with Tucker Carlson Riley gains she
killed it today in the hearings uh it's
on Thursday APF b.org check it
out I am uh Phil that remains on Twix
I'm Phil that remains official on
Instagram the band is All That Remains
you can follow us on Spotify Apple music
Pandora Amazon music YouTube you know
the internet out of curiosity ap.org uh
American principl project.org but if you
want to learn about the the gala with
Tucker and Riley it's a ppf b.org APF
b.org where is it it's in Washington DC
at the Ritz Carlton thanks for coming
man thanks for having uh I'll see you
all you later at Ian Crossland check me
out peace uh yeah see you guys on the
after show I am surge.com as always
pleasure having you here today my friend
again and uh yeah see you guys soon
we'll see you all over at timcast.net